we were sitting around and Steve now
Wiki my guitar player is very very upset
Guitar World they came out with their
list of greatest guitar players of all
time uh-huh and I was trying to explain
to Steve when they come out with these
lists they got to make them
controversial right they want people
talking
Steve says to me quote it's shameful
Brian May of Queen was given top honors
while of course everyone's beloved Eddie
Van Halen came in fourth and I said
Steve the two greatest guitar players in
the world are Jimi Hendrix and Eddie Van
Halen wait a minute where's Jimmy Page
he be number three Brian May is not any
of those guys Eddie Van Halen has got to
be number one Hendricks was incredible
but Eddie's level of game-changingness
it goes so far wait a minute well let me
tell you something you're a young guy
you don't remember when Jimi Hendrix
what Jimmy did right when you were born
all everyone had been influenced by Jimi
Hendrix already listen to me Steve I
know I'm your lead singer you want to be
in a band you want to stay in this band
because you know Fred had an argument
with me and now look where he is
am I right about that mine would be an
opinion but number one is Jimi Hendrix
no Eddie Van Halen you could even say
and I hate to say this Steve
listen to the riffs that Jimmy Page came
up with from Led Zeppelin he was also a
better riff Master than Eddie Van Halen
oh I could say oh you could say number
one number one you could say number one
Jimi Hendrix number two Jimmy Page yep
number three Eddie Van Halen and number
four regardless it doesn't matter but
but I I think there is best guitarist of
all time and then there's like first
guitarist of all time like based on what
though so they did it first I mean what
Hendricks did completely game changed
everything and like Eddie wouldn't have
been able to do what he did without that
influence but I think Eddie took it to
such a further level show me why you
think Eddie's number one go ahead you
got your guitar out go ahead all right
so Eddie unlocked complete new levels of
literally two hands on the fretboard
unlocked like stuff nobody could ever
imagine like everybody knows you know
like eruption
and then like the harmonic tapping that
he did
[Music]
well hey if you're going to get into
that what about Tom Morello Rage Against
the Machine Tom Morello does not get
enough respect on these lists I mean he
should absolutely be top 10 because it's
him Hendricks and Eddie did things with
the guitar that no one has ever done
it's so outside of the realm of what you
would even imagine you can do on a
guitar so you should be at least you
know all you think you know you're
probably right
but I I know authoritative you know you
know everything Tom Morello is
incredible though top ten for sure other
artists Guitar World ranked included
David Gilmore number six slash number
ten got to agree with that slash is
great Joe Walsh number 17 chose a great
guitar but Keith Richards number 18
Frank Zappa number 19 who they leave out
uh Fred other guitars I consider to be
great would be Prince Right Billy
Gibbons what about like a guy like Pete
Townsend to me he's one of the greatest
best Rhythm player ever Townsend's 21
and Joe Walsh is 17 and Dwayne Allman
16. on this list
I love these lists I love arguing with
people
I'll tell you who I like Lindsey
Buckingham Angus Young
DC oh no he's got to be at least top ten
I mean Angus and I would I would say
Angus and Malcolm together as a Duo I
mean like that's some of the most iconic
Rock riffs you've ever heard I had to
play some stuff go ahead play some Angus
Young
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
how did you have time to [__] girls I
mean you must have been practicing day
and night the way you're ripping like
that right Fred he's pretty good he's
great and the best lead ever is
Comfortably Numb go ahead Steve
comfortably
that's the only part I know that little
Ben that he does
it's so cool what about Stephen Stills
that dude can [__] play guitar and so
can Neil Young play the opening of
Woodstock
[Music]
something like that yeah and I said it
to Bruce I said Bruce you're very
underrated as a guitar player and he
agreed he's really good on the list or
not no no I'm insulting Steve Perry is
number 25. Steve Perry get out of here
Steve Perry
Johnny Ramone like completely Revolution
it's the simplest thing he does he just
plays like down stroke chords let me hit
down stroke chords go ahead
I could play that and Glenn Campbell
Eddie Van Halen asked Alice Cooper if he
could talk to Glen Campbell to get him
some guitar lessons because apparently
Eddie thought Glenn was a great player
yeah somebody came to life this morning
look at Fred on fire
era what's that I'm sorry what all right
yeah Jeff Beck was a great guitar player
all right no Jeff thank you Jeff I gotta
actually mop the floor with Eric Clapton
I gotta put the genie back in the bottle
I don't know what I got into Fred but uh
no no no it was pleasurable
foreign